I feel like I'm a natural for your
podcast uh podcast I think I should if
you actually yeah I actually want to
come on I mean we would love to have you
because you know if you're looking for
people with uh an awkward past who need
to come clean I'm your man uh well a
deep well I bet well that's do you want
to come on less now is that no you
called me a deep well past present and
future what are you talking about I
turned into such a cool guy now I am
Chuck Bass
you're about the age
[Applause]
to the age of the Chuck Bass disposition
they had the disposition of like a of of
a of a Yakuza member
that just just points and no it's and
Men die oh it's so true and also the
amount of brown liquor yeah you know
that's the thing I love is it'll be like
two o'clock in the afternoon and he's
throwing back drinking it like water
yeah drinking it like water and I'm like
oh no that [ __ ] you up and you're
17 yeah and you've you're you wait you
have algebra in an hour
through advanced Industries
yeah he's he really is Montgomery Burns
from The Simpsons he's Mr Burns and he's
a kid and you're like how did this
happen but uh well this made me really
happy I was so glad that you could come
in and do this and you know what blew me
away is that we never met yeah no never
I mean and and
um and I thought that was you know I was
on my way in here and I was like wait a
minute I've never met Penn Badgley and
told uh my my family that I was going to
be interviewing you today and got major
points that's great yeah no seriously
that it is a ritual for us and
um my daughter's off at college now but
when we get uh when we all get together
one of their things is we we watch some
Gossip Girls oh really yeah still that's
yeah that's really cool to hear honestly
sometimes yeah my wife sees me watching
one alone I get in trouble because
suddenly I'm a pervert
and it's like yeah no he's lying down
but I'm standing because I've I've taken
the Spader method and I'm I do it uh
yeah and I'm just I'm rubbing my chest
and I'm watching a Gossip Girl from like
2006. and you have no expression on your
face right because no it's just dead
just a completely dead face
he just he just did a really dead face
oh
so then it's like you know Rufus just
made waffles and I'm like
the thing is I'm most about the waffle
it's the it's the waffles in them it's
not the beautiful women it's look at all
that breakfast those those cards no
one's having any
why are you wearing a vest again
you really do you really do oh I watch I
watch I gotta go I gotta go I can't eat
any of this eat it
[ __ ] greatest you are the only person
who's talked about the breakfast on that
show I think everybody is that I don't
know it was like it was like an inside
joke with us well with you guys
you guys we're watching probably
paying attention Rufus waffles are like
rufus's waffles are
as far as I'm aware they're a thing yeah
I mean I think no I I think if you win
you said fan site no no I think if you
went on I'm saying if you went on a fan
if one was to go go into that world I'm
sure they talk about it no I did not I
did not if you did well I didn't go on
as myself
I was Melissa age 50 no Christ's sake no
I'm saying that anyone who watches the
show yeah if you're if you're talking to
a sentient person at some point you
notice that think of the greatest brunch
you've ever seen like you're at a rich
person's wedding yeah and they put out a
brunch that's that costs a couple
hundred thousand dollars that is the
breakfast that they have I I've watched
the show I just was paying attention to
what everybody was wearing how
attractive everybody all I see is the
amazing breakfast the waffle all of them
all of it and you guys always take a
little nibble yeah and then I'm out of
here and you take off and then you go
and get a coffee someplace
I'm sorry I took this in a weird
direction we were here to help young
people understand that
their problems and their issues and that
it's okay to feel awkward and I I took
it to my own place which is I want to go
back in time and finish those breakfasts
they were they were really good and I
have to say they were I always wanted to
eat more yeah I'm sure you did I'm
imagining Frank McCord
ah you wish
TV